this is kigo an AI powered guide
designed to help all students learn kigo
is not just for students though teachers
can use kigo too in fact when teachers
access kigo their device will transform
into the teaching assistant they've
always wanted let's take a look upon
entering K Migo's dashboard you're able
to see all of the wonderful things that
con Migo can do conmigo can give you a
class snapshot into your students
activity the last seven days
it can summarize your students chat
history so you can see what they've been
up to need help with a upcoming lesson
plan conmigo can help with that too
feeling iffy about a lesson that you
about to teach con Migo's refresh my
knowledge will help you prepare for it I
can use conmigo to help me come up with
a creative lesson hook that gets my
students excited about an upcoming
lesson conmigo can help me write
learning objectives for that unit as
well
well kigo can help me create a writing
rubric for my students next essay or
assignment and kigo can write unique
thought-provoking exit ticket questions
that I can use as checks for
understanding I can also use kigo to
collaborate with my students to create a
fun class summary poem that I know
they'll
love ready to see kigo in action great
me too I'm going to start off with
refresh my knowledge because next week
I'm covering a unit on the parts of
speech and it's been a little while so
I'm just going to type in parts of
speech I also have to let kigo know my
grade level seventh
grade amazing with one click of the
button conmigo is able to give me a
overview of the five major Concepts and
then offers to support me a little bit
more by offering to quiz me on the topic
and learn through
conversation now I want to come up with
a creative lesson hook for my students
so we are going to cover
nouns these are good but I would like to
make it funny so kigo can you make it
funny absolutely humor is a fantastic
way to engage students I couldn't agree
more thank you so much kigo now could
you help me create a lesson plan on
nouns to introduce the topic to my
students I would love one on
introduction to
nouns and again with one click of the
button kigo creates an incredible lesson
plan for
me wow this is incredible okay can we
please print this this is
amazing kigo included the learning
objective
the activities that my students are
going to do the exit ticket key terms
the resources that I'm going to need and
then a lesson summary this is absolutely
incredible in just a few minutes kigo my
new teaching assistant has saved me so
many hours of planning time to help me
create a quality lesson plan for my
students incorporating kigo into the
classroom is going to be a GameChanger
for teachers K Migo's insights and
suggestions are going to enhance
classroom learning and make teachers
lives Easier by saving them so much time
so that we'll have the ability to focus
on what's important our students thank
you
kigo